yes you're going to break the law so
long as no one is hurt there is a
British Wildlife TV presenter
by the name of Chris Pacman he's on
channel four in the UK and he put this
video out himself uh prepping the people
because uh he's thinking about breaking
the law to save the climate it's
absolutely incredible this guy he's a
he's a true hero go
it's time to make up my own mind and
decide
if I think it's time to break the law
what are we going to do about it
an overwhelming number of people
recognize that we are in danger they
fear for their amongst their children
fighting for the future of life on Earth
no government no major political
ever significantly addressed the issue
you haven't been listening to us the
climate activists now I'm not asking for
anyone to break the law there were so
many lawful ways to get involved Raise
Your Voice post the poster sign a
potential Banner go on a March Lobby
your local MP
however for me myself when significant
and obvious danger so
but I've got to raise my voice
if you're an activist
that's already made a decision that yes
you're going to break the law so long as
no one is hurt
and there's no lasting environmental
damage
then you'll have my support and
personally
I think
I've reached a point where I now
consider it the ethically responsible
thing to do
foreign first up did you guys note how
many times he touched his face in the
middle of that thing you know the thing
that I reference all the time there's an
episode of Seinfeld where Jerry's
talking about how when you're lying to
somebody you touch your face and that's
like the tell that you're lying somebody
in the higher up on your face that you
touch if you're scratching your head
while you're telling someone something
that means you're like seriously lying
remember James Clapper the former CIA
director under oath when they were like
are our intelligence Services uh spying
on the American people and he's
scratching his head and he's like not
wittingly it's like this guy can't stop
touching his face but okay first off
okay congratulations if you live in the
UK or I guess anywhere else because that
video did go viral he's got your back if
you break the law that'll help
um also there's nothing you could do the
weather's not coming for you it's morons
like this who are trying to use you
that's what it is but I think we decided
that uh during the afternoon today when
I have a little bit of a break I'm gonna
go out because I have a backyard here
with some trees so a similar background
is that and I'm gonna get out there and
Connor we can do some sort of soft
camera thing like yeah there's yeah he
all the camera stuff available to us and
I'll touch my face a lot and I'm going
to basically just take that script we'll
get the actual script and I'm just going
to talk about taxes because I don't like
taxes and if you aren't going to break
the law because of Texas then I'll be
here for you I'll save you if you don't
want the IRS to come to your house like
what what what
that actually would make far more sense
right like I don't want my I don't want
my tax dollars funding award in Ukraine
and I'll help you with the IRS comes to
arrest you